[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit bella italia geht es bergab
und nicht ohne grund wird das land in
dem einst nicht nur die zitronen blühen
schon seit geraumer zeit ist der kranke
mann europas gehandelt
denn neben griechenland ist ist das
einzige land der eurozone das heute
ärmer ist als noch vor 20 jahren ja das
ist die traurige wahrheit
es wird geschätzt dass der italienische
bürger seit 1999 durchschnittlich 73.000
euro verloren hat ein land in scheinbar
nicht aufzuhaltenden nieder dank all das
ist jedoch überraschend wenn man bedenkt
wo haben sich heute kaum noch jemand
erinnert nämlich dass italien in den
1990 er jahren eine aufstrebende
treibende kraft europas schau dir das
doch mal diese grafiken
[Musik]
kaum zu glauben im jahr 1992 waren die
italiener sogar reicher als die dritten
das waren jene jahre als my lucky
unangefochtene modehauptstadt war die
aktienmärkte dominierte und sängerinnen
wie laura pausini stadien in ganz europa
doch all das ist schnee von gestern um
dir ein vergleich zu geben in den
neunziger jahren wuchs italiens
wirtschaft und 38 prozent
in den letzten zehn jahren nur noch um 2
5 prozent nicht pro jahr sondern
insgesamt werden der ganzen dekade
hinzu kommen noch gigantische schulden
italien ist die volkswirtschaft mit der
fünf höchsten staatsverschuldung der
welt um die eine vorstellung zu geben
die italienische schuldenlast ist was
doppelt so groß wie das gesamte
bruttoinlandsprodukt des landes die
brasilien und egal welches ranking wir
uns anschauen italien ist quasi das anti
schweden das heißt wenn es irgendeine
von diesen ranglisten ansehen die mit
wirtschaft bildung oder irgendwas mit
leistung zu tun hat liegt schweden
normalerweise auf den vorderen plätzen
italien er am entgegengesetzten ende
[Musik]
all das beschreibt die situation bevor
die italienische wirtschaft und
gesellschaft und hatte lok das vollends
wieder gekribbelt wurde die du dir also
vorstellen kannst ist die situation
danach noch viel schlimmer italien war
ja eines der ersten länder außerhalb
chinas das vor dem neuen corona virus in
die knie gehen und das ist umso
schlimmer wenn man bedenkt dass in
italien ein problem selten alleine kommt
[Musik]
italiens erholung nach der pandemie ist
durch die politische krise gefährdet
aber auf welche politische krise genau
bezieht sich diese schlagzeile also die
wahrheit ist eigentlich dass das was der
rest der welt unter politischer krise
versteht in italien den ganz normalen
alltag darstellt und ja wenn die
italienische wirtschaft ein desaster ist
dann ist das größtenteils die schuld der
politiker nur wenige länder können sich
mit einer derartig schizophrenen politik
posten italien ein beispiel der normale
prozess in dieser demokratie ist ist
dass ein bestimmter kandidat die wahlen
gewinnt und dann vier oder fünf jahre
lang regieren nicht wahr
sicher es kann misstrauensanträge oder
vorgezogene wahlen geben aber das ist
ziemlich ungewöhnlich eher die ausnahme
in italien ist das exakte gegenteil der
fall
es ist quasi ausgeschlossen dass jemand
der italienische ministerpräsident seine
auszeit zu ende bringen kann er ja auch
leichter damit du eine vorstellung
bekommst die durchschnittliche regio in
italien hält zwei jahre durch allein in
den letzten zehn jahren hatten die
italiener sieben verschiedene training
minister natürlich ein italienischer
politiker zu sein wo es ein ultra
stressiger job sein
aber dafür gibt es auf der anderen seite
alles andere als einen mangel an diesen
jobs nur wenige länder verfügen über
mehr politiker als italien allein wenn
wir die mitglieder des italienischen
parlaments und senats zusammenzählen
kommt er auf 951 parlamentarier
mit anderen worten italien mehr
abgeordnete auf nationaler ebene als die
usa oder die europäische union und ein
volk das derart gut mit politikern
versorgt ist muss es doch unglaublich
mut haben die machen doch tagein tagaus
nichts anderes als sich um das wohl
ihrer wähler zu kümmern oder etwa nicht
nun schon der große italien kenner
johann wolfgang von goethe lieferte uns
hierzu einen kleinen anhaltspunkt noch
ist italien wie ist verließ noch
stolpern die wege jeder sorgt nur für
sich ist eitel misstraut den anderen und
die meister des stars sollten nur wieder
für sich na klar wollte so ist es sie
alle denken an nichts anderes als der
bembers und da sich das auch in den über
200 jahren seit goethe italien besuchte
nicht geändert hat wollen wir uns im
heutigen video auf einen ganz bestimmten
italienischen politiker konzentrieren
nämlich den meister des großen geldes
von dessen segensreichen kompetenzen
auch die außerhalb italiens schon zwar
genügend profitieren durften oder auch
nicht davor stellen supermarkt
mario draghi wurde am samstag als
premierminister vereidigt um eine
einheitsregierung zu führen das stimmt
italien bekommt 2021 wieder einen neuen
premierminister
diesmal aber nicht irgendeinen wald um
diesen politiker wir sprechen hier vom
großen mario draghi und wenn du dir
dieses video von irgendwo in europa
anschaust da hast du wahrscheinlich das
autogramm dieses herrn bereits in
kleinem portemonnaie ganz genau
wir sprechen über den ehemaligen
präsidenten der europäischen zentralbank
ezb der mann den wir alle unter dem
namen super mario kennt aber warum
nennen wir ihn super mario nur um uns
über ihn lustig zu machen weil er in
reallife auch nur ein hüpfender klöckner
ist da gerne prinzessin aus dem fan von
riesenschildkröten rettet nein kann so
gar nicht so was können sich nur japaner
ausdenken der wahre grund ist nämlich
weil man draghi nachsagt er habe
superkräfte okay erklärt du denkst
wahrscheinlich wirklich der markt immer
wieder voll ab was soll denn der fürst
superkräfte besitzen nur worüber ich
hier spreche ist die macht der worte
ach du bitte mal auf folgenden satz die
ezb ist bereit alles zu tun was nötig
ist um den euro zu erhalten
whatever it takes und glauben sie mir es
wird reichen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tage nachdem er diesen satz gesagt hatte
beendete europa die ganze schuldenkrise
einfach so schwuppdiwupp aus dem haus
wie durch einen zauberspruch natürlich
gibt es du das alles eine ökonomische
erklärung über die wir in einem anderen
video sprechen werden aber alles was uns
von jener sternstunde der menschheit in
erinnerung bleibt waren mal eine
legendäre figur die legendäre des mannes
dessen einfach worte dazu dienten den
euro zu retten daher wir uns heute die
frage stellen kann denn super mario auch
italien vor seinen politikern retten
wird er italien aus der krise
herausführen wie einen messias wie will
er das anstellen welche welt
erschütternden worte werden diesmal über
seine lippen kommen
heute werden wir all diese fragen
beantworten aber lasst uns zuerst noch
schnell einen blick in die geschichte
werfen
[Musik]
die zuckerrohr jahre diejenigen von euch
die wie ich schon ein gewisses alter
erreicht haben denkt ihr wird anlockt
und dabei in europa aufgewachsen sind
werden sich vielleicht an das goldene
zeitalter der italienischen musik
erinnern die zeit in der zelle cherry
mercury st laura pausini für den
radiosender zu hören war und wir alle
bilder von sabrina salerno auf unseren
schulen hatten
[Musik]
na ja ich hatte die nie aber ich war ja
aus war damit auf jeden fall war dies
die goldene ära italiens die italiener
waren genauso reicht wie franzosen und
deutsche tatsächlich investierten sie
damals massiv in osteuropa als gäbe es
kein morgen
in städten wie prag gibt es zum beispiel
ohne selige gebäude den italienern
gehören aber das ist eine ganz andere
geschichte
die frage laute daher warum weiterhin so
reich nun dafür gibt es viele gründe
hauptsächlich war der reichtum italiens
jedoch auf folgende sache zurückzuführen
wirft man einen blick auf diese grafik
hier siehst du den wert der ehemaligen
italienischen währung der italienischen
lira gegenüber dem us dollar
sie sehen kannst war die italienische
lira eine sehr weiche währung und was
bedeutet das nun sie wurde
kontinuierlich abgewertet zum beispiel
bekam man 1976 für einen dollar noch 840
lehrer
14 jahre später mehr als 2000 und
deflations scheuer mitteleuropäer denkst
jetzt sicher
das muss ja übel gewesen sein für die
wirtschaft und deren wachstum nicht wahr
nun stell dir mal eine italienische
modefirma vor die ihren feinen fummel in
den usa vertreibt wenn die lehrer
abwertet erhält sie dafür den gleichen
dollar betracht dank dessen hat sie den
preis in dollar senken und
wettbewerbsfähiger sein
normalerweise erhöht eine abwertung der
währung daher die exporte eines landes
zumindest kurzfristig
aber was ist der nachteil einer
abwertung nun auf lange sicht hat unsere
bekleidungshersteller keinen anreiz
langfristig zu investieren denn zum
beispiel wird jede maschine die im
ausland kauft für ihn teurer sein als
für die konkurrenz die moral von der
geschicht italien investierte nicht der
erhöhung der produktivität der
arbeitsplätze sondern wurde zum billig
heimat zu china europas
[Musik]
ab den 70ern bis in die 90er jahre
füllte es die weltmärkte mit logos
produkten
sie machten das gleiche wie andere aber
eben billiger was lief also schief nun
es ist das einfach das china europas zu
sein wenn das echte jeder noch wie ein
dornröschen pennt und mit einem noch
nicht auf dem weltmarkt kuriert und das
alles änderte sich im jahr 2001
[Musik]
china tritt der welthandelsorganisation
bei endlich du dir vorstellen kannst
wenn dein wichtigster wettbewerbsvorteil
der niedrige preis ist gut viel glück im
wettbewerb mit china praktisch über
nacht mussten italienischen
schmuckstücke mit chinesischen
konkurrieren und das gleiche galt für
alle andere art von krebs was hätte
italien also an diesen punkt zu tun
können die lehrer noch weiter abwerten
das ging nicht mehr und warum nicht nur
aus diesem grund
auf diese weise hat italien sein haupt
wettbewerbsvorteil verloren und seitdem
hat es die halbinsel nicht mehr
geschafft wir auf die beine zu kommen
ok du fragt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
wäre es dann von italien nicht besser
aus dem euro auszusteigen um dieser
ewigen ab dass spirale endlich zu
entkommen nun vielleicht sollte die
frage eher lauten ist es für italien
möglich wird das fähig zu sein oder
seine währung permanent zu manipulieren
warum zum beispiel ist italien nicht
innovativ nun schauen wir uns dazu die
faktenlage an alle eu länder investieren
im schnitt in forschung und entwicklung
21 seit ihres bruttoinlandsprodukts
italien jedoch nur 1,20 prozent
egal welches bildungsrenditen wir uns
anschauen italien ist das land mit den
schlechtesten leistungen und richtig
frage wo sie italiener falsch abgebogen
warum haben sie es so weit kommen lassen
wir werden uns das alles mal genauer
anschauen
das land der bürokratie in italien gibt
es zwei berufsbilder im überfluss
politiker und beamte und wir reden hier
nicht von irgendwelchen beamten laut dem
iwf waren italienische beamte 20 prozent
mehr als angestellte in der
privatwirtschaft tatsächlich verdienen
sie praktisch genauso viele die ihre
deutschen kollegen obwohl das
durchschnittseinkommen in deutschland
viel höher liegt als in italien
und es ist praktisch unmöglich sie zu
feuern die privilegien der beamten
erreichen ein solches ausmaß dass wollen
jetzt nach der großen krone lockdown
viele italiener deswegen auf die
barrikaden gehen die italiener schießen
sich auf die bürokratische branche was
sie eine aber ist das wirklich der grund
für italiens probleme die hohen beamten
betriebe nein das ist nicht das
schlimmste problem das größte problem
ist dass sie unglaublich effizient sind
italien versinkt im graben der
wettbewerbs unfähigkeit zum beispiel vor
wir haben ein unternehmen in dänemark
und wir müssen einen kunden verklagen
wenn nicht zahlen will nun im schnitt
werden die dänischen gerichte so ein
fall in etwas weniger als einem jahr
gelöst haben
italien und wird das gleiche verfahren
drei jahre dabei mindestens denn wie
auch immer die prozedur aussieht in
italien dauert alles zwei bis dreimal
länger als in jedem anderen europäischen
land vorantreiben vor steuern bis zur
gründung eines unternehmens aber warte
ein moment denn das problem ist nicht
nur dass die bürokratie ineffizient ist
das problem ist dass sich eine alles
lähmende bürokratie einfach überall
breit gemacht hat bis in die letzten
ritzen und hier kann ich dir ein
beispiel geben dass wir hier bei visual
politik vor ein paar jahren selbst
erlebt haben eine zeit lang hatten wir
eine italienerin im team die als
dokumentarfilm und arbeitete
sie wollte auch mit den großen
italienischen zeitungen corriere della
sera oder der reparationen zusammen man
nun um als journalist in italien zu
arbeiten brauchst du eine erlaubt ist
das ist richtig du musst eine
journalistin lizenz beantragen
fast überall auf der welt ist so ein
presseausweis ja eine reine formsache
aber um italien also was dran zu kommen
musst du erstmal berufserfahrung
nachweisen journalist und egal wie viele
dokumente und bescheinigungen wir
unterschieden haben aus der hervorging
dass sie bei visual politik gearbeitet
hatte die italienischen behörden
erkannten diese erfahrung einfach nicht
an
youtube ist das was zum essen und seit
wann kommen youtube als
medienunternehmen ansehen
und auch eine idee davon zu geben was
den italienischen amtsstuben abgeht es
gibt eine verordnung mit dem genauen
prozedere dass du befolgen moskau ein
medienunternehmen zu gründen und für den
fall dass jemand darüber nachdenken ein
italien ist nicht gerade dafür bekannt
medien zu haben die internationale
maßstäbe setzen das fazit in italien hat
man es als kleiner existenzgründer sehr
schwierig von innovationen und wachstum
ganz zu schweigen die bürokratie zu
einer unsichtbaren moore geworden die
viele unternehmen in der
schattenwirtschaft landen lässt während
es in deutschland tausende
mittelständische unternehmen gibt die in
ihrer nische weltweit führend sind ist
der produktive sektor italiens in zwei
gruppen aufgeteilt große unternehmen wie
die fiat gruppe oder der energiekonzern
eni deren wettbewerbsfähigkeit jedoch
immer weiter sinkt und familiengeführte
kleinstunternehmen und genau deswegen
befindet sich italien schon seit
jahrzehnten im freien fall
tja und die lockt aus waren der letzte
nagel auf den sagt die frage ist nun was
können sie tun um irgendwie zu wachsen
kann mario draghi auch bekannt als super
mario die dinge wirklich drin genau
darauf deren der es einen blick werfen
also aufgepasst
marshall plan damit sind wir wieder beim
heutigen protagonisten ins super mario
von 2012 bis 2019 präsident der
europäischen zentralbank fahren ist sein
wichtigstes vermächtnis war die rettung
des euro lang des massiven ankaufs von
staatsschulden und der
liquiditätsspritze für die banken aber
wir alle werden unsere anhänger wegen
eines satzes rädern der die europäischen
finanzen quasi über nacht verändert hat
und jetzt seid ihr wahrscheinlich schon
ganz toll auf seine neue orte gespannt
also diese lauten wir haben heute wie
die regierungen der unmittelbaren
nachkriegszeit die möglichkeit oder
vielmehr die verantwortung einen neuen
wiederaufbaus zu beginnen mario draghi
aber was genau meinen tragen mit diesen
bezug auf die unmittelbare
nachkriegszeit ganz einfach nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg schickten die
vereinigten staaten riesige mengen an
geld nach italien um es wieder
auszubauen im rahmen des legendären
marshall plans und genau jetzt im jahr
2020 sprechen wir über einen neuen plan
der unterschied ist dass das geld nicht
aus dem schenken sondern aus brüssel
kommt was eigentlich bedeutet
hauptsächlich vom bayerischen
steuerzahler und draghis oberste
priorität ist nun zu entscheiden was mit
diesem geld geschehen soll
das italienische parlament billigte
draghis konjunkturprogramm
wir sprechen hier über eine riesensumme
von sage und schreibe 200 22 milliarden
euro
ganze 13 prozent des bip italiens und wo
landet das geld wie hat es trage
verplant nun was das gesamte geld wird
für den ausbau der infrastruktur
verwendet hauptsächlich im stream hatte
die modernisierung von eisenbahnen
straßen und so weiter mittlerweile wird
aber wohl auch der größte brocken
erkannt haben dass italiens hauptproblem
nicht darin besteht dass seine züge
deine osten italiens liga problem ist
die größe und funktionsweise seines
staates
und deshalb hat sich draghi etwas neues
einfallen lassen er will fast ein
drittel seiner kollegen feiern
[Musik]
die italiener haben in einem referendum
dafür gestimmt das parlament des landes
um mehr als ein drittel zu verkleinern
manche mögen dies eine populistische
maßnahmen nennen außerdem war es auch
nicht tragisch
die idee hatte tatsächlich wurde sie
schon diskutiert bevor super-mario an
die macht kam
auf jeden fall kann italien durch die
reduzierung der abgeordnetenmandate
schon mal über eine milliarde euro über
einen zehnjahreszeitraum einsparen aber
diese maßnahme gehen weit über das
finanzielle hinaus denn vielleicht wird
es ein schlankeres parlament leichter
haben öfter ein kurzes zu finden und
vielleicht dass draghi ermöglichen seine
amtszeit auch zu ende zu führen es ist
ein zeichen dass trage die politische
struktur italiens ändert denn dies ist
bitter nötig doch draghis plan hört
damit noch lange nicht auf er will die
steuern senken und vor allem bürokratie
abbauen
er zielt auch darauf ab die öffentliche
verwaltung zu modernisieren dazu gehört
die verkürzte von zivilprozessen und 30
prozent von strafprozessen um 25 prozent
sowie die förderung des wettbewerbs und
die beendigung von monopol praktiken
ferner so dass sogar ein schnitt im
beamtenapparat geben aber es ist noch zu
früh um zu sagen wie dies in die tat
umgesetzt werden kann
im moment können wir nur sagen dass die
super mario magie zu wirken beginnt
draghi hat seine ersten 100 tage bereits
mit einer zustimmungsrate von mehr als
50 prozent abgeschlossen
der härteste teil der namenstag steht
aber noch bevor denn wenn du denkst dass
der abbau von bürokratie in einem land
mit millionen von prächtig verdienenden
beamten kann den widerstand hervorrufen
wird kannst du italien nicht aber jetzt
bist du an der reihe
glaubst du dass mario draghi in der lage
sein wird verträgen italienischen ducati
ein ende zu setzen sowie der klempner
der bösartigen schildkröte oder wird die
schildkröte ich meine die italienische
pokert er super mario besiegen und seine
legende begraben kann italien überhaupt
aus seiner zwei jahrzehnte währenden
krise herauskommen und welche anderen
probleme siehst du noch im süden europas
teilt eure meinung bitte wie immer mit
uns und auch allen anderen ich hoffe
dass auch dieses video gefallen hat was
ja gibt es mit dessen freundin und
vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]